and here we are theoretically live
i shall know in just a minute
we got here hello john
they're all trekkie
carowind meg glad you made it
bailey's gozer
hi ben
ah
oh cappuccino crafts good to see you
bruce miss wicked wolf
hey ian
good to see you here
oh
how am i doing i'm doing all right a
little bit tired a little bit uh worn
down trying to get back into the
work groove
following the holidays
but i'm doing all right so
i appreciate that
uh
still wearing the roughness shirt from
that tick tock yeah i shot a few tick
tocks earlier today because i was all
pretty
uh from a video that i shot which is
pretty typical if i feel like i look
nice i'll try and squeeze a couple of
tick tocks in
the funny thing about this shirt like i
i swear
it had sleeves but like just
they just busted off i don't know what
happened
yeah right
boba fett oh that's right yeah that's
well for me that starts tomorrow
uh i am going to try and watch that
and
every time i think i'm i'm i'm done
with a little bit for with um
with shows
that another one starts up
drunk no my i'm not willing to get drunk
that said
i did put a little more
rum in this eggnog than
i'd intended to
oh well
oh that's nice
let me just switch that over so
reminder for folks who are if anyone is
new here um i will try and follow the
chat to the best of my ability i make no
promises about catching anything the
only thing that will guarantee that i'm
going to see your question is to do a
super chat which will also get you a
heart of appreciation from me but i will
try and keep up with the chat as best as
i can regardless of that but we'll just
move forward i don't have um
a particular
um topic in mind today it's just you
know
it's the last stream of the year
cheers
anyone's interested in hearing a defense
of the witch's familiar moffett's
handling of the daleks in general my
first video is up now part two out
tomorrow oh i should check those that is
that is a um
it's a tricky one to try and defend i'm
not gonna say it's impossible i'll be
curious to see how you go about doing
that i remembered your video on vera
wild channel about your trip down south
and it helped me get through a bout of
dysphoria i had yesterday oh
oh i'm really sorry that you went
through that um i am glad to hear that
it helped you but i'm also sorry that
that you went through that
uh now that you've seen encounter do you
think you could work as a tv series
it could
i'm not
uh
i'm not sure i'd be interested in seeing
it as a series
i did really like it though i've
actually i've had a couple of songs from
it stuck in my head all day uh we don't
talk about bruno and surface pressure
have both been in my head off and on all
day
i learned that one of the youtubers i
like allegedly turned out to be a turf
how could it be that blind the thing is
like
don't beat yourself up for not realizing
sooner because
you know as is evidenced by how
how blatant jk rowling had to be before
most people were willing to accept that
fact about her it's
it's difficult you want to give people
who make things you like benefits of the
doubt
for as much as you can
but
you know when you actually hit the point
where you're like okay i can't pretend
this isn't happening don't beat yourself
up you're not the one who did something
wrong so you know
on my video someone asked a question i
wasn't sure how to respond to would you
mind taking a look i'm assuming they
attended it in good faith i can
try you might have to like
shoot me a uh
twitter nudge or something to remind me
because that's that's the kind of thing
i'm gonna forget
about um
[Music]
don't suppose you're a walking dead fan
no
that that that would be a no erica thank
you so much for the super chat really
appreciate that do you have a
favorite video you created this year i
particularly liked your reaction video
to your old video casting uh the doctor
as a woman great stuff i hope you're 22
is like you delightful oh
thank you so much i do have a favorite
video that i made this year
i'm not going to say what it is though
because i actually it's one of the
things i talk about in the video coming
out on saturday saturday's video is
going to be kind of an overview of 2021
mostly focused on what i thought were
the best pieces of entertainment i
experienced in the past year but also uh
starting talking about the channel stuff
that had gone on and
the video that i'm proudest of that one
was a lot of fun though
um i i am i am quite happy with how that
turned out with luca and now encounter
the name bruno seems to be disney's
latest punji bag yeah but bruno i think
gets a reprieve and in kanto
a bit
you know it's
i mean the song the song doesn't treat
him nicely i'll give you that
hi and i'm new to your channel
uh appreciate it
prefer not to be called bro if you don't
mind that'd be uh that'd be great
have i seen the witcher no i have not
it's been on my
to try out list i hesitate to call it
to-do list because i want to see if i
actually care about it what after my
right arm i fell
uh day before christmas i fell on i i
was
walking uh my mother's dog for her and i
i didn't even slip on ice i tripped over
my own feet
so
that was one of the spots where i landed
so that was that was fun
something i've just thought of is the
best version of the ronnie possibly
basically live octavius from into the
spider verse
uh yeah
actually yes
i'd say so
um
just learned that i wrote
2631 pages this year i'm exhausted
heck of a lot more than i wrote
uh what did i get for christmas except
for the group for the
the crews
i don't i don't know what that was bruce
um well i got a number of things
actually this shirt uh was a christmas
gift uh from liz
the the sort of top layer on my lips the
uh the gloss
that was a gift sent to me actually by
somebody who's in the chat uh i also was
sent this i the
it probably won't be able to read it but
it says what fools these mortals be
so
that's my favorite shakespeare quote
from my favorite shakespeare play
so i got that i got some um the reason i
have no nail polish on right now
is i was is i got
well i didn't get i was given a um
a set of gel
nail polish and the uv light to like dry
them properly um and i need i need to
try that out so i have taken all my nail
polish off um so that i can do that
properly
hopefully tomorrow
maybe
maybe thursday
i
i don't know
like i never get to
get to things when i think i will
i slipped and fell on christmas on a dog
turd
yeah that's uh
that's that's not ideal
um
if you don't
tell everyone what i got you
i will scr oh
oh now i'm being threatened
oh dear
i've
hm excuse me i got some
very lovely
um
makeup uh eyeshadow palettes from meg
thank you may
wonderful
um oh
super chat captain omni thank you very
much i appreciate that
could a spiderman be non-binary if the
man in question referred to human like
superman would be superhuman or is that
a reach fanfic debate
um
well
given that
the
given that spider-man is like one of the
most written about
um you know because of the whole daily
bugle and j john jamison thing it would
not be difficult to pitch the idea that
the reason that the person is called
spider-man despite their own identity
being non-binary is that is what the
press and the media have dubbed them and
they're just rolling with it because
it's what everyone's calling them
regardless
so i think that would be the easy work
around because otherwise like your
argument is sound
but i feel like there was a debate to be
had there
uh if they chose that name for
themselves however if like that's just
what everyone's gonna call them
regardless of their own identity and
given that any version of spider-man
usually the secret identity is super
important so like correcting people on
pronouns might even be a concern about
um
you know giving hints as to what their
their civilian identity might be they're
just rolling with it you could even
factor that in as part of the narrative
if you wanted to
have a little bit of dysphoria result
from that not a requirement but it's an
option if you felt like it
i think there are total with totally
ways to make that work
uh how are you and i got autism and i'm
good and i got news on doctor who
adventures and the news is that they're
having a second channel
it's called doctor
doctor who adventures plus oh cool i'll
have to look into that
which marvel movies do you think would
work better as a series and vice versa
uh
hmm
um i think
i think the eternals probably would have
been better as a series
i'm not sure
that there's any of the movies that are
sorry any of the series that i would say
would have made better movies
um i mean like hawkeye could have
totally been done as a movie but i think
they used the breathing room they had
decently so
i don't think there's any i'd switch the
other way around
just listening to what the frel episode
twice shy i'm so glad you saw that the
episode was a copy of red dwarf oh god
it so is molly like it
like down to a frightening level of
detail
that one is
uh
let's see here
it's been a long last weekend it's
tuesday i apologize for my craziness in
advance you are entitled to be as cranky
as you need to be meg don't worry about
it
uh
right see if i can catch up with chad
again
tell us how you feel about the shazam
movie um
it's fine
i mean that's
just gonna where i'm at it's
it's fine
it's fun i get why people who
like the shazam character or like the
more whimsical uh approach in specific
like really like it i it's it's fine
if you don't want to comment on this
fair but are you going to talk about
lindsey ellis quitting youtube i figured
somebody was going to end up asking me
and
no i'm not
planning to talk about that
um it's not impossible it like
it's distinctly possible that a notion
or a thought might lodge in my head and
if i can't shake it luke's maybe i'll
make a video because that is the impetus
for a surprising amount of my content
but as of right now i don't plan to talk
about it
um largely just because
i haven't had the spoons to
try and untangle and parse
all of the conversations around lindsay
ellis for honestly the last like what
half a year
or so or more than that for for
everything that's been going on most of
this year
i haven't
i haven't had the brain space
um
because
i just haven't
and not having like sorted through all
that
i would feel i would feel uncomfortable
commenting overall on what's going on
with her
because i i would just feel like i'm
walking into a landmine um
people have formed very
strong feelings
on something that i am just kind of like
i don't even completely 100 percent get
uh
why there is such a harsh divide and i
am i am loathe to step into a minefield
uh
unless i think i have a point
and right now i i
don't i don't
when's my next p.o box video i don't
know i like i kind of stopped doing them
because
honestly um
even around holidays or my birthday
there usually wasn't enough of an
accumulation of stuff in the p.o box to
have it like
be a video i suppose like maybe it's
something
i don't know maybe as a patron exclusive
the pl unboxing while i enjoy them they
have in the past felt a little indulgent
and i've i've kind of had mixed feelings
about doing them in general i don't mind
integrating them into the live streams
which i should get better about
um
but i actually do devoting a video to it
i don't know something feels off about
it
um
that's not to say i don't love getting
stuff because i do
and i certainly if it's anything
that i can show off i will absolutely do
that um i mean
give you an idea i did get sent
some stuff to my p.o box
my annual delivery of
garrett popcorn
got one of these uh for a number of
years now
i do enjoy these it takes me a little
while to get through them this is a
smaller bucket which i'm kind of
thankful for i've been sent the huge
tubs before
uh
uh
is that soco eggnog in that glass vera
no it's golden eggnog
have i seen any of superman and lois no
i haven't seen it
disney is making a biopic about jim
henson called muppet man what are your
thoughts i won't have thoughts until i
see it
i mean there's certainly plenty to make
a documentary about
i'm sure jesse's take on it is fair
she's good at that yeah i haven't
watched all of jessie's take either i
haven't i haven't even had the spoons
for that um
so you know
that's sort of where i'm at with all
this
uh
so do you think the snyder verse is
finally on its way out
uh
i would like it to be
i don't know if it is
i think
i think a fair amount is going to end up
ultimately depending on
how the next few
dc movies perform how the flash performs
how the next shazam performs how black
adam performs
aquaman two and the reason i say that is
if all of if all or most even of those
underperform
um then the
the folks who push for the snyder cup
might jump on that
as a way to try and push the idea of c
you should bring back this continuity
because this other stuff isn't doing
well
and while
uh two years ago i would have said you
know they'd try but it wouldn't matter
like at this point i don't know
i don't know with warner brothers
anymore
i really don't
captain omni thank you once again for
the super chat i appreciate that greatly
super fan of shazam ever since he was
captain marvel remember his thing is
always being even nicer than superman
just imagine that one well i mean
in the dc movies being nicer than henry
cavill superman is uh
it's not difficult
it's pretty easy in fact he's um
kind of a dick
[Laughter]
eggnog is where sugar and eggs come to
die but like in a tasty way
i love that meg that is gold
what are you most excited for next year
personal or movies series books i don't
i am
i feel like i am losing track of what is
coming out it just occurred to me that i
oh
i should figure out if i'm gonna do
a most anticipated 2022
um video or not i didn't do one for 2021
because after 2020
i wasn't prepared to assume that
anything that had been announced was
actually going to be released on time
oh i should figure out if i'm going to
do that
i don't know i i got to think about that
because i don't really have a an answer
off top my head
oh we got a few more super chats tom
thank you very much
you get a heart are you excited for
batman
thoughts on don't look up um
well um my reaction to the latest
trailer for the batman and i really wish
that i wish warner brothers would stop
it
with that like it really is annoying to
have to clarify talking about are you
talking about suicide squad or the
suicide squad are you talking about
batman or the batman like just stop
stop with that but anyways i did a
reaction to the most recent trailer
uh and people are not happy with me
because
i am not sold in fact i'm becoming less
and less and less
sold
as uh as i see more trailers and people
are not happy
with me
about that
i i forget
how much uh
dc fans hate me
until i express skepticism
about anything that they like and then
like locusts
oh hazel hogan thank you very much for
the super chat nothing else sent but you
get a heart absolutely jesse
showing up in the chat good to see you
vera you're rocking the lesbian
lumberjack look today yeah right
um
ready to
knock down a tree using my
skills
new type jb lee thank you so much for
the super chat speaking of spidey do you
think the clone saga should have ended
with amazing spider-man 400 with aunt
may's death because that feels like a
very good ending for peter
um
i don't
i don't have a fully formed answer
to that
question
because
i haven't fully tried to read all of the
clone saga it's too big into sprawling
in too much of a freaking mess
absolute mess
so
i forget what happened in it and what
happened when
i'm just gonna go ahead and say yes
anything that would have made the clone
saga shorter would have been a good
thing
so sure why not
why not
erica thank you for that super chat
would you be okay with sharing the name
color of the lipstick you're wearing if
not no worries i think it's fetching
this is
two different things this is maybelline
color stay
i forget the name of the shade it's sort
of a
wine red
and then it's nick's
uh gold gloss
over that uh nyx nyx
so this is a combo
uh it's still too realistic and still to
harumph grim gritty they should do
something like batman and robin again
okay well let's not let's not go crazy
but like there is middle ground
there are there are like just look at
the batman animated series you can be in
the middle
between dark and
camp
there is a line to ride you do not have
to pick a side in that war
erin ooh thank you very much aaron i
appreciate that
quite a bit aaron oh did you ever watch
the batman versus tmnt movie i haven't
yet i still need to
i want to see that one that one looked
good it looked fun
i had to see if that's on hbo max cause
some of them are on there but not all of
them i gotta check on that one
what are my thoughts on the peanut movie
from 2015 it's great
i love that movie it's fantastic
um
easily the best thing blue sky ever did
ah
what we got since then
it's nice to hear night voices here
knight his voice is here yeah we we keep
it we keep it pleasant around here jesse
for the most part
why would you not like camp i loved the
camp
camp
all right
camp is really difficult
to nail
because
the best camp
i
i can't think of another way to put it
the best way to do camp for me
is like this
but a lot of things that do camp do it
like this
if that makes sense
that's sort of my issue
[Laughter]
lumber jack daniel
jack daniels is actually my mother's
preferred drink
scenes single are the way we are on the
level that gays now can have cringy
hallmark christmas movies as well that's
equality
yay
my favorite tone is one that flip-flops
between camp and dark uh the gotham
rtd formula yeah
that actually was
a huge part of what i love about
gotham is that it is
it is undeniably dark
for how many people die the visual
palette of the thing it's gruesome at
times but like it's all so silly and
it's it's so rare
for batman projects to remember that you
can still be silly while being dark and
it doesn't have to kill it
gotham knew that
i missed that show i gotta re-watch that
show liz re-watched it recently on her
own
um captain omni once again thank you
so very very much
thoughts on pro wrestling because i'm in
a wrestling training camp and soon
captain omni will be powerbombing fools
through the ring
oh yeah
um
i
i had a super brief interest in
professional wrestling when i was
god
like
eight to ten
um
i
i admire the absurdity of it i've never
gotten into it
um a lot of it has to do with the fact
that at least large-scale professional
wrestling is um
well i mean first of all it's often a
level of ridiculous that's a little much
for me but the bigger issue is that um
you know as an adult i know how
predatory uh the wwe is and i'm not
really
uh
up for
you know seeking out smaller local uh
amateur wrestling venues i'm not that
committed i'm more supportive of those
in general but um yeah i mean
professional wrestling i get the appeal
i'll say that
not my thing but i do get the appeal i
get it
i got another super chat they're coming
in a lot
uh so
a heart for you adrenaline hey good to
see you
uh how is steven universe coming along
looking for recommendations for partner
and 13 year old now that they finished
the owl house um okay so my kiddo and i
are
about halfway through season one season
one is super long
on steven universe um episodes are only
about 11 12 minutes but there's like 50
of the damn things so we're about
halfway through season one
it's fun and it's cute i know it like
people have told me repeatedly it gets
better and deeper and more interesting
later so right now it's just fun is is
what it is
excuse me she's enjoying it uh if you if
folks liked uh the owl house i would
recommend checking out amphibia uh
amphibia is a little bit um
uh more silly
than owl house is but it is it is fun
and i do enjoy i like our house better
but amphibia's good stuff
and so at 13
this might be a weird recommendation
given that it's a bit of a different
vibe but at 13 they might i
you make the call but they might be old
enough to watch arcane
which i would recommend
um
[Music]
so
beerus strikes me more as a derby girl
than a wrestling
uh than wrestling um i mean i love derby
names
i i love
that
um i have a pitch for a small-scale
batman movie mad hatter toy maker as the
villains with themes of nostalgia
childhood innocence that could work
um
see one of my one of my favorite um
batman villains will
never see the big screen outside of a
tiny cameo possibly a joke
and i get why
but
um
i like the vantrelliquist
i don't know why i don't even know why
i just do
planning on seeing the hilda movie with
your kid i'm really excited for that's a
thing
i did not know that that was a thing
i i have not previously been informed of
that being a thing sorry i gotta check
see what am i getting
what is this
huh
okay
deal with that later
um
so where did i leave off you know what
actually i'm gonna stick a pin in that i
got i got to say something in a minute
um but anyways let me just let me get
catch up on the super chats um new type
jb lee thank you very much
it may just be me but in a lot of movies
a lot of media like tv movies how come
queer affection is shown less than
heteroaffection in terms of kiss of sex
and kiss scenes because people aren't as
comfortable with it
they still aren't uh most creators like
intellectually know there's nothing
wrong with it but a lot of people still
just have visceral stuff that they are
um
trying to get over
meg thank you so much
i watched the new matrix and to be
honest the aging makeup drives me nuts
is there anything effects wise that is a
pet peeve of yours that can totally ruin
a movie or show for you
i'm not i mean like
bad effects will always move it but like
there are there aren't that many things
that like even if it's done well i don't
like it there aren't a lot like that i
will say this though
when it comes to completely cgi
creations
if they are humanoid
almost nobody can get the mouth and the
lips to move quite right
there's like fine details about the way
lips move
and because my eyes are drawn to the
mouth when someone's talking i see like
that's not right
it doesn't look right
i think the thing is most people when
they talk cgi creations they talk about
the dead eyes
um
because i guess a lot more people are
drawn to the eyes whereas i'm drawn to
the mouth so i zero in on what's wrong
with the mouth and i feel like eyes have
gotten pretty well handled but like
mouths they're still bad
and captain omni omni
i can talk i'll have another
drink uh aew is new and far better than
wwe and is killing them by taking all
the talent wwe is stupidly releasing i'm
joining swa championship wrestling well
congratulations on that and yes
avoid the wwe at all costs so
i need to take a quick second
and talk about boundaries
because
uh the face that i made
um is because somebody
texted me
uh
like to my normal number
which i know it's not impossible to find
i know it's up in a few places
um
and or if you look up the like
registered business it's probably on
there
but to have someone text me and be like
can i ask you questions i'm a fan of
your stuff
uh no
no you can't and like
i strongly suspect there's someone who's
been sending messages to the council of
geeks facebook page like as a
as a message
that i haven't responded largely because
i don't know what to do with them
it's these
walls of text and i barely understand
what the person is asking for they're
all over the place
but they keep sending stuff
and
they're like asking me if they can pay
me to interview them and i don't
understand what about or why
and i strongly suspect this is the same
person
don't
[ __ ]
do that
if you send me something
through normal channels
and i don't respond to you
it may be because i have adhd and don't
get stuff
it may be because i haven't noticed it
or to be
blunt about it it might be because
i do not wish to engage
with what you have put in front of me
so finding other means to try and reach
me
especially if you have messaged me
multiple times for the same means so
it's pretty much guaranteed that i
didn't just not notice to then try and
find me through other means including my
[ __ ] phone number
which i would really prefer to never
have to change
i've never been in a position where i
ever thought such a thing was necessary
but i will change my goddamn phone
number
do not
do that
you are not
entitled to my time
or my attention
i give both
fairly regularly and fairly freely but i
do so within the bounds that i am
comfortable comfortable with
do not step outside those bounds i'm not
even scared
i'm angry
and as bad a cliche
as it is
you won't [ __ ] like me
when i am angry
so that having been said
sorry if i put a little bit of a damper
on the um
on the evening
but having seen that
um
i needed i needed to say
that
out loud and not have it festering in
the back of my head for the next 25
minutes
or however long i keep it going
so
that that had to that i had to expel
for the time being
uh i'm not going to say publicly on
stream what i am or am not going to do
about it at this time because
the fact that it is happening
and i'm not okay with it is as far as i
want it to go publicly at this point
um so you'll forgive me not answering
that miss ms wicked wolf
i hope those women out there who cosplay
scorpio and powered up evil in also do
mother russia from kick ass too
i haven't looked i've been meaning to
look to see if someone has done powered
up evil in
because
yeah
yeah definitely
uh give me a second here
sorry i'm just checking something
um okay
just keep you on top of something
uh i will apologize for the swearing
insofar as i try not to swear
um
on this platform
if i can help it but
you know
i'm upset
so
do you like the idea of a companion
being the child of a previous companion
not really
not especially feels needless to me
um because that to me either means
they're going to effectively be
uh almost like a do-over on that
companion and you're just gonna have it
evoke
that previous companion which is like we
had that companion already why are we
doing it again
um
and the
other the other option would be to do
something that is not doing that in
which case it's basically the original
character why
so what was the point
i don't know
i had a couple drops left
is anyone read girl genius yes not all
of it i'm way behind on it but i um liz
and i
uh
we reviewed the omnibus which is the
first three collected volumes uh for
tough like a girl
so um
yeah i i enjoy it quite a lot it's fun
uh it's it's um
bonkers it's over the top i enjoy it
they're releasing dc league of super
pets starring dwayne johnson as krypton
kevin hart has aced the bat hound what
are your thoughts i don't care
that's my thought i do not care
um
will you do a live reaction on stream to
hilda and the mountain king
trailer i just read the first three
books and watch the first three episodes
um
maybe
i uh i'd have to put headphones in
to do it
uh
just because otherwise the sound of it
would get the um
get the archived version of this pulled
might even get the stream shut down
live uh
what about the child of a companion be a
villain i would need to see a more
specific pitch than that
as a
as a broad
concept i
don't feel like i have a good enough
sense of that bookworm
thank you very much i appreciate that
uh i'm having a lovely christmas
vacation in georgia no snow here i now
have a doctor who mad libs i've got one
of those like yeah my kid gave me that a
couple years ago and a mug will be
watching hawkeye episode six when i get
home that i can watch your review hope
you had a good christmas thank you
bookworm i did i did have a good
christmas um a little bit stressful
but like
that's the holidays
so
you know it's it's a thing
uh tried to donate but super chat isn't
working just wanted to say thank you for
starting me on my gender journey i'm so
much happier now you're awesome have a
great new year oh molly
thank you and like can i just say molly
it's been really
wonderful
seeing you become more comfortable
that's been i've that's been a privilege
to get to see
so
thank you thank you very much
let's see here
um
oh uh you're talking about um
phil foglio
yeah his
some of some of his work has been um
spicy
have you seen the film where the wild
things are yeah
i saw it once
it's weird
like it it's weird and interesting way
it's a spike jones movie so like it's
not gonna be uninteresting but like it's
a weird
film
um
i get what it is it's not actually a
movie for
children it's a movie about childhood
and i get that
i still don't really like it
that much i haven't rewatched it in ages
i haven't felt the desire to do so
so
um
i really wan i i recently
really
i can talk is there anything left in
here
there we go
i recently finished watching doctor who
in order to about it ended with flux
yeah well i mean ended with flux for now
there'll be other stuff later it's fine
have you read the book version of where
the wild things are was read to us in
kieran de gardner of course i had that
book growing up
um
so yeah i'm well familiar with
it gotta go happy new year everyone oh
happy new year to you too meg get some
rest
and i hope things go well for you
uh
what else we got
uh i've got on good authority that phil
may be the dirty old man
uh but kaya is the perfect
if that in fact is their dynamic i love
it uh i never read
xenophile
um i can never get hold of i actually i
should check to see if there's scans of
it anywhere
it's the kind of comic that like in my
teen years i would have loved to have
gotten a hold of but never could figure
out how to do it
my favorite my favorite dr seuss book is
one that nobody ever talks about
uh it's the butter battle book
i really like that one as a kid i also
really like scrambled eggs super which
is one of the ones that the um
at the dr seuss estate decided to stop
publishing so i really got to hold on to
my copy of that
um
what beverages would you pair with
certain doctor who episode city of death
has to be a wine and a smashed bottle
oh
oh
hang on i gotta write that down
sorry i um
i i just had a uh
a random idea for a possible future
video based off that comment so if uh
let's see
drinks to
pair
with doctor who
videos
that
that might be
that might be an april first release
i don't know
i like then again like i've had a number
of ideas
that like i think could be really fun
and funny i just haven't gotten to them
just because like i'm i'm i feel like
i'm always behind trying to keep up with
my standard schedule so when i have
slightly more out there ideas trying to
find the time for them is
difficult
because i had like i don't mind saying
that one out loud because i feel like
there's a decent chance i might do that
there's another one that i really want
to do
but i don't want to say what it is
because like i've gone
almost two years now since i initially
had the idea and have made no progress
on it so
is the butter battle book even relevant
anymore um
in terms of its specific condemnation of
the nuclear arms race
not necessarily because it was very much
specifically reflective of the cold war
um
but i don't think that its overall
message of
escalation out of fear is a bad thing i
don't think that's become less relevant
i think the specific um
uh analog that it was meant to be
doesn't apply as much anymore
i'm going through a bit of anxiousness
and uncertainty may i have some
reassuring words okay uh black cover
deep breath
i know things feel
crowded
piled up on
encroaching in i know but
this too shall pass
and you will remain
you'll be okay
all right
i know it can be hard
and i know that it's not always easy to
remember that and
feel
that it's going to be okay
but that doesn't mean it won't be
something feeling like too much
doesn't actually mean that you're
incapable of getting through it
you can surprise yourself
a lot
and
i have faith you'll be okay
hopefully things
uh will be back to normal next year i do
hope that this pandemic will end
it's never gonna end
uh
well correction the exact shape of it
may change but like
general authority is at this point that
cove is going to become the new flu
and variants are gonna you know you're
gonna probably need a booster shot
annually and
variants are going to pop up
year over year this is probably not
going away forever it should die down
enough that we can like i think
here's the thing the idea of getting
back to normal i.e the way that we were
living prior to the pandemic that's an
idea i think a lot of us need to let go
of not just because out of a stubborn
well it's not gonna happen give it up
but i mean and more more in the sense
that the way that we were living
was part of what allowed this thing to
spread as widely and horrifically as it
did so maybe we need to be making some
adjustments to our day-to-day lives in
the first dang place
um
and maybe that's a lesson to take away
and that while we can we can find
something that is
better than what we've been dealing with
for the past two years i
don't know if the goal of getting back
to how
everything was prior to the outbreak is
actually a wise one
i only realized the other day that city
of death and shadow both have villains
whose name begin with
uh
s-e-a-r-s-k-a
scar
yeah yeah that's true
this is what comes up having a country
that's
that's
years that we've had enough of experts
that was that was an amazing clip i
remember that clip
not not to be an [ __ ] about it
but
i kind of appreciated the fact that oh
we're not just massively stupid in this
country
good
we're not the only country putting up
with that
so yeah i want to do the beverages in
doctor
who episodes video but you probably have
a better knowledge of drinks than me
i mean
probably more experience with drinks but
that's uh
that's neither here nor there ooh
if you're time to mention the discord
thank you carowind thank you very much
i'm going to pop over to the discord
real quick check to see if there were
any questions in there
reminder at this point that the
discord is a patreon exclusive perk
um and
uh putting questions in the appropriate
channel over there is the other way to
guarantee that they get addressed if
you're not doing the super chats and
today
nothing okay
that was quick so i was just plugging
i'm not giving up hope i'm not saying to
give up hope ms wicked wolf i am saying
that
think about what it is that you're
hoping for
and
put some thought into whether or not
that's what would be best i'm not saying
giving up hope as a general notion
i'm saying that a lot of the changes
that have been implemented in the wake
of the
pandemic
should stay in place
being able to facilitate work from home
this much
should stay in place
you know
the the level of assistance being
offered to people who were financially
strapped before the pandemic happened
that should stay in place
so while i know that for a lot of us the
idea of getting back to normal is about
being able to go to restaurants into
movie theaters and concerts again like
that's all lovely and we'll probably
have that again
there was a lot of other things involved
in the normal
that weren't
good
and some of those things actually got
better under the pandemics the pandemic
forced them to get better
so
you know i'm saying
let's not
go into this idea of oh bringing
everything back to the way it was before
because it was great no it was a mess
and maybe we can have it be slightly
less of a mess coming out of this that'd
be awesome
new type jb lee thank you so very much
for that super chat how come the dark
phoenix saga is seen as the most iconic
x-men story even though the story
doesn't deal with the usual mutant
metaphor of hate and fear
um that's a good question actually i
think part of the thing with the dark
phoenix saga actually has less to do
with its iconic status as an x-men story
specifically and more to do with its
iconic status as a comic book story
overall like
dc tends to get most of the credit for
ushering in the
darker age of superheroes
with things like the dark knight returns
and watchmen but marvel was heading
there in their own way prior to that
with some of the stuff that went on with
spider-man like the death of gwen stacy
and with the stuff that was going on in
x-men and x-men the dark phoenix again
specific
to not only have your good girl
go that bad but then to kill her
that was a big deal it was
it was groundbreaking it was
earth-shaking that story
not just as an x-men story but like in
terms of its impact on the medium as a
whole
for how long it went on
at the time that was almost unheard of
as a continuous story comics were still
largely being done being one and done's
occasionally two parts over a couple of
issues they weren't being told that way
it was a game changer in a lot of ways
so i think that its status has to do a
great deal
with its impact overall on comics
it's um
then just as an x-men story if that
makes sense
uh
will we ever reach a point where i don't
have to wear a mask
i hope so
that's that's what i've got i hope so
in the uk it's night time for me
uh didn't want you before this is my
first time and it's midnight we'll get
get some rest uh furious time lord
superman adventures
get some rest and have a good night i'm
gonna be wrapping up my uh here myself
soon as well they're still playing
christmas music where i live yeah here
too they have a tendency to play it
right through
uh
until the 31st where they
play like the hottest music of the past
year in anticipation of new year's and
then
then they stop but yeah i know say
same here same here
slightly less of a mess sounds like the
an election slogan of the democratic
party yeah pretty much and they wonder
why nobody's that enthusiastic about
them that basically was just going well
well i get
i guess
that's
technically better
that's how the democrats make me feel
so much uh
vera you're are you saying idealized
memories of the time before covid
shouldn't be the basis for our plan
forward unsubscribe
meanwhile doom patrol has been killed
over and over since the 60s doom patrol
was pretty nice though x-men was a lot
x-men was one of the biggest stories it
was one of the big
mainstream hits of marvel so while i
don't want to take away the impact of
things like doom patrol or other comics
that were a bit more daring you didn't
see that in the main big ones
they didn't do it
are you planning to see the movie don't
look up i don't know i saw the trailers
it looks
like it might be okay it also looks like
it might be really really really painful
contemporary satire
i don't know about that
who do you relate to more from wicked
elphaba or
glinda elphaba for the most part
doctor who is like my escapism it's my
comfort show
and
uh it's very hard to criticize but i can
but i feel like i'm tired of having to
defend my enjoyment of chidnal well
jamie like you do for me you don't have
to defend your enjoyment if you tell me
that you've been that you've enjoyed
flux or any of the other chipneal
stories i am not gonna go
why i'm gonna say that's great
i'm happy for you i wish i did
so
anyone who is demanding that you defend
it
because they don't like it and you do
that they're being jerks
you are not obligated to defend it i
will frequently defend stuff because
like
it's
it's
some of the stuff that i do
and i will also frequently pull stuff
apart but just because i pulled stuff
apart you don't have to defend it to me
if you if you just want to say
i disagree and i liked it
great
that's great you do not have to defend
your opinions
or your views to me even if i'm holding
the opposite view even if i'm holding
the opposite view passionately and
possibly slightly shouty
you don't have to justify yourself all
you have to say is well i enjoyed it
great
thank you
i'm happy for that thanks for letting me
know that other people enjoyed it it
helps me to hear that
so
um
erica thank you much for the super chat
i appreciate that if you do a drinks
pairing with doctor who episodes then i
would like to request what nibbles you
would have with said bevy's
oh this is becoming a project now
uh
it's just that i keep getting lots of
y's instead of that's great when talking
about doctor who yeah i know
i know
the
a lot of fandom has gotten very
argumentative
as if like taste doesn't matter
and that's one of the things that that
can really be irritating
for me and like i will grant
i am someone who is going to apply my
analytical thoughts to try and parse my
own gut feelings
but you don't have to do that
you don't have to be able to explain why
you like a thing
but fandoms i think fandoms have been
taken over by would-be debate team
hacked
who want to feel like they won
and so they build a case in favor or
against something
and are prepared to duke it out with
people who they see as being on the
other side of their opinion but like
it's just a piece of entertainment did
you like it great did did you not like
it well it's hard to hear that
i mean i know i overanalyze it but
that's my job
the fact that the fandom as a whole has
really
dipped into that is
frustrating the mitchell's versus the
machines is awesome i yeah i've i've
been meaning um
to
to get to that one i keep i keep
forgetting about it is the thing i want
to watch it and then i forget about it
then i get then i see something reminds
me i'm like i need to see that and then
i forget again
i just watched don't look up a couple
hours ago it's a little bit of both in
my opinion it had some good stuff and
also some insufferable heavy-handed
satire overall i quite liked it though
see i feel like
the satire even if it's the minority is
gonna kill it for me if it feels like
if it feels smug
i i'm gonna hate it
uh
will you ever give avatar the last
airbender another chance um
probably not
look here's the thing
i
just about finished
the second season of avatar
and it's it's fine i don't dislike it
but after the first season
when i had a lot of nitpicks and things
that weren't working for me basically
everyone seemed to give me a pass on the
basis of oh don't worry you'll love
season two
and i got to the last episode and
i didn't love it
again it's good it's not bad i'm not
gonna say it is but
i don't
here's the thing if i passionately
disliked it if i thought it was crap
then i might finish it and make a video
because i'd feel like i would have an
axe to grind and i would have energy to
propel
you know
making a case about that but when
ultimately my opinion is just kind of
i understand why it's important i get
its influence
i am not grabbed by it especially i just
feel like i'm yucking everybody's yum at
that point
and the idea of sinking the time into
watching a whole nother a whole third
season of a show that i'm not in love
with and will probably not want to do a
video on
no i probably won't
again it's not because i think it's bad
it's because
i don't think
i have anything really to say about it
is it good yes do i love it no
that's kind of it
you're a safe space youtuber very
comfortable talking about stuff here in
this community you made i'm i am
incredibly grateful
to hear that jamie i i try
i try really hard
to to
foster the best community i can not just
for my own sanity but so that people can
feel
safe and welcomed in here
i'm really excited for turning red i
keep forgetting that that's coming out
ah
oh man this is why i hate tuning into
live stream especially when i'm doing it
late sorry um but i do need to get some
supper don't want to pause and i don't
wanna uh no it's it's fine it's fine uh
real life julie i'm i'm wrapping it up
soon anyway so don't worry about it i
swear if you make this beverages video
and it blows up i'm gonna sulk so hard
whispers make it a
caller um
we'll we'll see if the idea sticks in my
head more than just this evening um
because it might fade because honestly i
should probably get back to that other
idea that i had that would be good
and i just haven't done
um
i don't
don't like avatar last night i don't
dislike it i just don't love it i see
why it's influential i see why
definitely anyone who was watching it at
the time that it aired it like expanded
the idea of what these stories and these
kinds of shows and animation uh for a
western audience could be
but i've i didn't watch it at the time
i'm watching it now in the wake of tons
of things that have built off the
foundation it laid so going back and
trying to enjoy that foundation
i can appreciate it but actually love it
or like it just for fun not
so
much
that's fair i respect that stance thank
you renee i appreciate that
okay couple couple more um
super chats and then i'm gonna wrap up
uh new type jb lee once more thank you
so much which green goblin do you prefer
norman or harry
um
by and large norman
i feel like
harry harry as the goblin only works
insofar as how it factors into his
um breakdown as a person and his
spiraling and his substance abuse
but actually like as the goblin as a
villain
uh i like how the goblin factors into
his story but that doesn't mean i
necessarily like him as the goblin i
would go with norman that said uh marvel
should not have brought norman back from
the dead that was a stupid idea and i
hate that he's still around
there we go
uh
speaking of uh
avatar the last airbender while watching
it for the first time i immediately
spotted talking points that people
complain about woke shows today does
that make me
a bad person
no it just means you've absorbed too
much of that stuff and it it worms its
way into your head
it's a thing that happens
tara
thank you so much
tara tara i feel like i've asked that
before
ah
either way
tara i'm gonna go with tara because
that's how it's spelled i went i went to
grade school with the tara i think
that's why i went that way tara
thank you very much for the super chat
just stopping by to say hi well hi to
you too
and i am gonna wrap it up yes
thank you carowind um
so tomorrow 10 30
eastern time
um i will be streaming
um
i haven't spoken about spider-man in a
video i have
yeah i have you mean the new one yeah i
did a review on the break room
and it was ranked on my list
um but anyways yes tomorrow 10 30 a.m
eastern time twitch.tv council of geeks
i will probably be finishing up
um death's door if if i am as close to
the end as i think i am
um and then after that i'm not sure what
i'm not sure what i'm playing next it's
currently being voted on by my patrons
if anyone here does support me on the
patreon and you haven't voted in the
poll yet between the two options for the
next game i'm going to play on twitch
it's been really close all day so you
might want to weigh in on that
um
so
i am going to uh wrap it up
and i hope that you all have a wonderful
day
i hope that
you remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
happy new year
and
of course lest we forget
mccabe